depuis quelques jours la grande partie
d'entre vous pensent à faire ce geste
enfin en tout cas on l'espère un geste
qui ne peut potentiellement servir à
rien 6 2 secondes après et bien vous
faites ça un objet essentiel dans notre
vie de tous les jours et qui contient
presque autant de bactéries que la
cuvette des toilettes et donc forcément
vecteur potentiel du corona jones
alors dans cette vidéo on va vous
montrer comment le nettoyer sans le
rendre inutilisable
et pour que ce soit le plus efficace
possible première chose déjà l'éteindre
et le débrancher ensuite il ya un
certain nombre de choses évidemment à ne
pas faire avec son téléphone de plongée
jamais votre téléphone dans l'eau
savonneuse
c'est forcément tentant 6ème article est
résistant à l'eau mais il suffit qu'il
soit tombé une fois que la coque soit
légèrement déplacé que l'écran soit
légèrement fissurée pour que l'eau
s'infiltre deuxième chose à ne pas faire
laver son téléphone avec une lingette
classique pour les mains en fait c'est
beaucoup trop imbibés de liquide et ça
risque d'endommager le téléphone ensuite
dernière chose à éviter c'est de laver
son téléphone avec ses parties abrasif
de l'eponge c'est à dire la partie qui
gratte ça va forcément endommager votre
téléphone le rayer enfin vraiment ce
n'est à ne pas faire ensuite quand on en
a fini avec les choses qu'il ne faut pas
faire voici enfin les choses qu'il faut
faire pour un smartphone sans film
protecteur il est recommandé d'utiliser
de l'alcool isopropylique à 70%
isopropylique retenez bien c'est super
important
ou alors une lingette désinfectante à
base de chlore ou d'eau de javel on
précise évidemment que si vous décidez
d'emploi de la javel il est recommandé
de ne pas trop en mettre et enfin la
solution qui apparaît comme la plus
efficace c'est d'acheter un film
protecteur alors je vous la corde c'est
certes un peu moins confortable au
toucher pour les doigts c'est pas trop
cher et c'est très utile vous allez voir
pourquoi ça va vous permettre de laver
votre téléphone sans risque avec des
produits un peu plus fort puisque c'est
la protection qui prendra tout voilà
alors n'oubliez pas que ça aussi c'est
un nid à bactéries et que évidemment il
est recommandé de le laver régulièrement
pour ne pas transmettre le yacht
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]